hey everybody is Jessie and today we're
gonna continue working on our handling
our form data which eventually yesterday
we finally got the file upload to work
so it took a while but we kept at it and
it worked out so it's really happy about
that
doing a little earlier than normal today
so I'll have to finish up finish this up
in about an hour and a half so a little
bit shorter than i've streamed that i've
been doing lately so probably the code
portion will finish up in an hour and
then after that we can do like a half
hour question-and-answer and then then
we'll be done for the day and for the
weekend but we'll see how much we can
get done with this I want to show you
some of the changes so I had some pull
requests and so changed a bit
if you want to look in the repository
let's see a brain
let me bring over the files changed here
so this will be easier to see what would
actually change
so Patrick submitted a pull request I
also get another pull request from Kevin
but it ended up they were doing a lot of
the same things so I ended up just
pulling in Patrick's request because it
had a few extra things and it was just a
lot easier to pull in one than to try to
merge so thank you to both of you for
for submitting these so basically we
have node 1 I I've read like so many
different ways to pronounce this but I'm
gonna say node mon-sol so we have that
now and that's gonna like watch our new
like custom server so that we can change
stuff in our server and it'll auto it
should oughta reload so we have a new
some new things like in our scripts here
so different ways we're starting the
server and this actually now this start
server gets called when we run start
so the normal start command has a little
bit extra on it now and what actually
ends up happening is it runs basically
it runs our normal server that we've
been running for you know for since we
started this project on for 3,000 and
then it runs the other one that we just
made yesterday on port 9000 or whatever
port we set it to and that's kind of
nice because yesterday we were like kind
of having to manually start it and now
it's just one command it starts them
both
and then that way we can go back and
forth we still have all the benefits
basically of both of them really without
any extra extra work so there's a lot of
other stuff here you can see like a lot
of a lot of variables added which is
nice and I'll definitely be probably
have to add some more in as well when we
start working with our api's but you can
check more of that out if you if you
want
and Patrick also put in some explanation
as well so that is available in the
repository also I accidently merged this
into master instead of custom server so
our custom server branch and our master
branch are now the same now I'm still
gonna do any new stuff in our custom
server branch but I don't know what I
was thinking and I didn't realize it
until it didn't say that the pull
request was merged and I'm like what the
heck I know I merged this and then it
hit me that I did it on the wrong branch
so after that I decided to get some
caffeine but other than that there's not
really been not really any changes oh I
did add one thing let me show you so
this is where I ended up basically I
added this on so I keep it distracted I
have my secondary stream on Instagram
but for some reason my phone keeps
falling down so I don't know why every
other day it stays like perfectly where
I want it but today it's falling down so
anyway so I added
this this part here so I was just kind
of looking through the repository on
github for node formidable-looking
through their examples trying to see how
they do things and I found this and I
thought oh well this would be cool at
least we can see if all our fields are
coming through and and how it looks so
now we know that we can get all our
fields here and do what we need to with
them within here so right now we're just
logging them but this is basically what
I want to work on today probably I don't
know I don't know if I'll do that much
more with with the uploads right now at
some point I would like to add in like
some security features so let's say
block out potentially malicious files so
I'm not sure if I want to get into that
today or not
probably want to do a little bit more
research I had added some things in in a
previous project some security features
but I could probably do a better job if
I spent some more time researching it so
if any of you have any ideas or any
experience with that you know please
please let me know but otherwise we're
gonna work on on handling this so we
need to grab this when you do a couple
of things with this this data so we need
to email we need to send two emails one
email to our project manager here in my
department and then we need to send
another email to the user and then we
need to send the data to
our project management system through
their API when we do that we're gonna
get some information back and that's
going to include a project ID number and
then we need to use that project ID
number to send the files and attach them
to that project I think that's all we
need
yeah I think that's all we need in the
current version of this we're also
sending data to a Google sheet but I
don't know if I want to do that I may I
don't know I'll think about that it's
always nice to have another backup but
I'm not sure if I want to I I kind of
want to set up some sort of database to
keep track instead of using the Google
sheet it might be overkill for this
project but I it's something I'd like to
learn how to do and will possibly be
using in future projects so it might not
be a bad idea to try it on this project
I mean that this project has a very
limited internal audience so the stakes
are not very high let's say if if this
crashed and I didn't do it right I mean
I'm not saying but worst case scenario
if it if it crashed and we lost a bunch
of data all we'd have to do is just call
up the people who submitted you know
their requests and ask them to tell us
what they wanted again right so I feel
like it's better to try out something
new on a project like this than to try
it out on let's say something that you
know an external audience would be using
a lot more people would be using it
would be more of a big deal if it messed
up so let me know what you think about
that I mean maybe I'm off with my
reasoning here but so we'll see so we'll
basically postpone the decision about
whether or not to backup to a Google
sheet to use a database or just to not
do anything and we don't really need to
make that decision now but just to let
you know what I'm thinking
maybe you know yet you all can think
about it and let me know I'm gonna go
just say hi to everyone now and the live
chat everybody
okay cool so my pronunciation I've done
a lot no daman is not so strange
jonbi says are you sure you don't
pronounce it as I choose you know to Mon
like it's a Pokemon that's that's pretty
funny my kids are really into Pokemon
right now I'm gonna have to tell them
I'm gonna have to make up some sort of
dad joke about that and tell them later
on and they probably have no idea what
I'm talking about
but they'll still laugh cuz they're good
kids
okay cool Kevin says that seems cool
with both service started you can test
that the file upload actually creates a
file without losing hot reloading while
making changes yeah yeah actually that's
yeah that was exactly so right before I
started the the stream I was just
testing it out and and that was like
that was kind of like the deal breaker
like wow that's that is really useful
Rowan asked where's the file go okay
Kevin says it's in the uploads folder
yeah so the the file right now obviously
is just saved locally but it'll be saved
you know on our server at some point
let's see okay so we have some some talk
about the database here so yeah I'm I'm
not sure what I'm not really sure what
I'm gonna use yet so what do you what do
you all think it looks like Royce is our
our DBMS all right I'm not familiar with
that what what is that
okay babak's is firebase okay cool yeah
actually I've heard of firebase have not
used it
so yeah I'm not anyway I'm still open
I'm still open to it I was researching
some okay so thank you thank you
it's relational database management
system okay so okay so we're talking
sequel versus no sequel databases right
is that - sequel being the relational
relational database I think I get it now
I get it I'm not like I'm very limited
experience with databases basically just
like troubleshooting a wordpress
database if it gets messed up and that's
that's the extent of my experience okay
cool yeah I was kind of thinking going
with something like a no sequel database
since like my very limited database
experience has been with sequel
databases and with WordPress
so I thought like hey well why don't I
try you know try something like no
sequel so I'm not really sure like I
said I just I have no idea what
direction to go with this so I'm open to
suggestions whatever I go with just
something really lightweight and simple
to start out with I don't you know I
don't need a lot for this project I
think it would be better to start out
with something simple just to get get
used to it and for later projects if I
need to move move on to something a
little bit more involved and that's cool
okay cool Kevin sent me the link to a
project that he did with database so I
am I'm gonna copy that and check that
out later on put it in my my list of
things my big list of things tasted okay
I figured out why my phone is falling
over today it's uh it's vibrating when I
get messages
and then after I get so many messages in
a row it just vibrates right off of
where I have it sitting so that's that's
fine
and I need to this is already in there
now so don't need that
I think we've used this already I don't
need that we've used this we've use this
okay we basically done this okay clean
up my little copy and paste file there
there we go now we have plenty of space
let me know if the text is too small on
this I think I left it the same size as
I had it for the video yesterday but if
it's too small I could definitely make
it bigger I did I saw one question in
here that I want to answer before I
start the coding so don't forget okay it
was Tyler so Tyler asked the college
near me just opened up a 24 week boot
camp what's your opinion on college is
opening up boot camps do you think they
are worth it I don't really know I don't
I don't have experience with colleges
opening up boot camps so Mike my
experience with colleges and computer
science in general has been they're
usually behind so wherever the industry
is they're like a couple years back at
least I don't my guess that the reasons
for that are just there's not really
very much incentive for professors to
stay on top of things
right because the the way it's
structured you know you set up your
courses you get your course materials
approved and then you can teach the
class without necessarily having to
update it that much you get used to a
certain textbook
you have all your your tests and
everything around there so it's just
like this the way it's set up is it
makes it really easy to keep teaching
the same stuff over and over again and
really difficult to try to do new stuff
so having said that I would be a little
skeptical of a boot camp put on by
University and I mean I work in
universities I'm definitely not anti
University in general but I would be
skeptical it would just depend on like
who's actually doing the teaching and
who's putting it on like is it are the
people going to teaching like people who
are actually building real stuff you
know in the industry you know
cutting-edge stuff and they're just kind
of partnering with the university to
have some credibility or is it actually
like university professors that are
putting this on and I'm not saying all
universities are like that or all
professors are teaching you know kind of
older stuff but that's just been my
experience just in general I mean there
are definitely universities that are on
the cutting edge like near where where
I'm at Carnegie Mellon is always really
good they're on the cutting edge tech
companies hire people professors and
graduates like right away from from
Carnegie Mellon all the time so I guess
it just depends on the on the school but
I would check if you can try to check
out who the teachers are and see like do
they have a github profile what kind of
stuff are they doing that's what I would
look at to determine you know whether
whether or not it's worth it rohan says
when i said they're a couple of years
behind he said try about a decade i was
trying to be nice
and i'm not like I've spoken with like
some of the professor's here at my
university and basically like their
mindset is it's not really like possible
for them to stay on the cutting edge and
still keep up with like the the load of
courses that they're expected to teach
to be full-time professor
so instead like they're they actor
they're trying to just give them the
fundamentals of computer science and not
try to do anything that's cutting-edge
so it may not even be their goal to try
to teach new stuff you know they're just
they're trying to teach them you know
good logic and problem solving and
that's cool and then they do it and
sometimes really old languages like they
might use COBOL here actually I know
like at the university that I went to I
did take one computer science course and
it was in C++ so even in even really
good courses use really old languages
sometimes like the Harvard computer
science intro to computer science course
starts out with C they do a lot of other
languages too so anyway that's just kind
of would be my reservations about about
doing it so it could be really good you
just need to do a little bit of research
on on who's teaching it
okay I'm gonna grab one more thing from
the live chat to copy and paste here and
then we'll get started
okay John B says maybe go with a sequel
a sequel light database okay that's cool
yeah like I said I was kind of leaning
towards a no sequel database but I
really don't have I I don't really know
enough about it to know what would be
better so I'm definitely relying on your
suggestions here okay all right so let's
get into it so first thing we're gonna
do I guess is maybe we'll try to send
the email that seems like a better thing
to do if if I can't do everything during
the stream it makes more sense to do the
email thing during the stream then to do
the sentence of project management
because like for the use case of sending
an email that's really really common so
we're probably be useful to more people
watching this or watching the recording
I don't know how many people use our
particular project management system so
may not be as useful to learn the
specifics of that particular API so I
mean ideally I'd do them both on a
stream but it may not work out like that
so let's just try to do the email thing
first I have used let's see what am I
using right now let me check on my other
screen I have the file I have it's a
private repository right now so I can't
share it because there's some API keys
and things I don't want to see what I'm
using because I think I'm a thing I'm
using email j/s I'm pretty sure that's
what I used
so let me know if you all have any email
clients that you really like let me know
I guess I'm currently using email j/s
where is it that I try I even tried to
clean up all my tabs in Windows before
the stream and it's still like a lot of
stuff I just have a lot of github stuff
open and it all looks the same and it's
all just a bunch of code when I go in
alright I'm just gonna go into my github
profile and find it again and that will
be faster
I feel legit now that I have so many
repositories that I'm using the
repository search function on github so
I don't know that makes me feel like hey
you got a lot of stuff on here there we
go I can't remember what I named the
original repository so and this one's
I'm really glad this is a private
project Ori cuz it's a mess I don't want
anybody to see it
let's see
yeah and it's really like the
organization of this repository is just
it's really I don't I don't even like to
look at it it's making me feel bad just
looking at it right now but this was I
think I started working on this almost
two years ago so I've come a long way
all right so basically let I'm sorry I
can't show you this but I don't want to
show my API keys to the world but all
I'm doing is just trying to find my API
keys for the email and verify that I am
actually using the email system that I
think I'm using also I'd like to see the
format that I'm sending this data in
currently and so my old project that was
using Ajax there we go okay
all right so I'm using it looks like I'm
using email j/s but it's going through
SendGrid the reason I went with email
j/s is because I needed something that
what client-side it was just like I had
no access to any back-end stuff and so
anything I did had to be client-side so
email Jas ended up being the only thing
I could find that would let me send
things client-side so I don't need to
keep using it
I could probably I could probably just
use Senger directly
okay
okay maybe I don't even have a key I
Karen let's let's look at email J s in
case you're not familiar with it
okay this is how
okay yes this is I'm sorry I'm this is
all coming back to me now I said this
helped a while ago yeah so this was a
way for me to get around
so like SendGrid would not let me send
emails client-side so this was like a
workaround for that where I don't even
actually send in any API keys or
anything you just litter it's just this
like it's this simple and then the
actual information for the SendGrid api
is saved you know on the on the site so
i'd log in and have that there and then
i can build my email template within
this okay so i probably won't need to do
this anymore
so i might just cut this out cuz this is
just one more step in the process that's
not necessary
so I really I did like this this works
really well but don't really need it
so I guess I'm gonna go straight with
with SendGrid
so I'll have to let's look up their
documentation and
let's check awesome so here's the send
good nodejs client awesome so we'll
check
okay cool
okay not bad it's not like super
up-to-date but it's you know within the
last year they've updated this this
looks promising
okay let's just try to do something
basic just to see you know what we can
send so
all right so first things first let's
add SendGrid to our project and I'll be
I'll be bringing in their documentation
back and forth as as we need it
okay
so we're just adding SendGrid to our
projects all right well that's working
I'll check the live chat
okay back to the coding bootcamp thing
Tyler says completely agree with you and
guard that most colleges are behind in
terms of computer science but looking at
the curriculum of this it seems pretty
solid they teach Martin stack and even
jump into angular and firebase can't
find out who's teaching but it's hard
situation jumped into considering is 10k
okay sounds like they work with Trinity
okay
yeah I mean that is cool that they're
obviously using some newer stuff but
yeah
10k that's like just to put it in
perspective as far as 10k like I when
when you count like the scholarships and
grants and stuff that I got I didn't pay
10 K for my entire bachelor's degree so
and that's probably even if you include
everything I had to pay for books so 10
K for a coding boot camp where you're
not you're not even gonna get a degree
that's a lot so I mean I would want I
don't know for me to do it I would have
to have some serious proof that this is
going to be awesome and that companies
are gonna recognize how how good this is
on a resume that you're gonna I get like
build things that are really great for
your portfolio that is that's just like
that's a lot of money like who that is
10k to just do that you know I mean
normally like people take out a loan for
that and stuff so it's gonna be more
than 10k when you end up paying it all
back yeah that's just a lot Wow
yeah I mean I guess it depends on where
you're where you're at - like if if you
have the money and that's cool go ahead
I'd be really wary of doing that if I
had to borrow yeah I mean just check out
there's just there's so many other
options that are less expensive that
potentially could work out I mean
depending on what kind of learner you
are
okay
okay cool awesome so Kevin you like
guess what I was thinking a minute ago
so I was looking at this and I'm sure
obviously you all saw it was on the
screen I was just kind of going through
this and looking and what it was what I
was thinking was wow look at all these
bears they need to be Const and look at
all these semicolons and so Kevin wrote
in the live chat here Jesse if you copy
code with a lot of semicolons and very
you can use NPM run lint to auto fix
some code styling issues exactly what I
was thinking I guess it's not I mean
it's not really a big deal I can always
just use like control fine and get rid
of stuff but that was that was cool that
you like you knew you knew what it was
going through my mind when I saw that I
wonder if projects like because I've
I've been seen a lot like trying to look
through different things for file
uploads and email things I've seen a lot
of the documentation uses this I wonder
if that would be a good opportunity to
get some pull requests and to just
switch the examples to use even just to
use Const I mean you know we'll leave
the semicolons alone to not bring up the
whole debate over whether or not you
should use them but I don't know maybe
updating it a bit just to use es6
because that's I mean even like browsers
support Kant's like right up off the bat
right don't I don't really know I mean
because I always use a transpiler but
it's just so common now you would think
like you may as well just you know
switch over to it all right
let's let's try this out
so within
let's require let's just require
SendGrid
so I'm not gonna copy over everything
because a lot of the stuff they have
there
actually I might need to yeah I'll need
to copy more at first I thought they
were just saving a lot of things to
variables and using them later but
they're not they're actually creating
like like new new helpers and stuff so
okay so off to copy more ever
all right I guess I'll just copy the
whole thing coffee the whole thing and
then we can rearrange it as needed so
let's run that what was that I need to
run lint okay let's see
actually I'm not sure that that that
went over our server did it yeah it did
okay I did first why didn't it well
they're not really sure what happened
but not a big deal let's just change
them
okay so anyway I see in the live chat so
Tyler I see like the conversation is
still going on about the bootcamp I'll
come back to that whenever my timer is
up here so I haven't haven't forgot
about it
we just want to get try some stuff out
here okay so let's see what we have TV
now from alright so let's change this to
my email so I can get the email
so yeah I'll leave the subject and
content as is now but we'll see if it
ends up being a pain I'm definitely
changing this this content right right
now it says sending the send Gert is fun
and easy to do anywhere so it may not be
true we'll see yeah I'll leave it like
that I just want to make sure it's sense
first if we can get it to send then I'll
actually make the content be you know
what we're collecting from this forum
okay this part of it I guess is would
play which word actually sentence okay
this is the part that actually sends it
yeah so let's let's put this part inside
here because this is where we're gonna
end up making it doing this anyway so
we'll just put it inside here for now at
some point maybe we'll want to clean
this up because this is this server
digest is gonna end up being pretty long
once we do everything that we're
probably gonna need to do but for now
I'm not not gonna worry about it so we
need an API key so let me let me log
into my SendGrid account on my other
screen
alright so I'm gonna make a new API key
just for testing actually I might
okay the way you can customize the
access that the API key has
actually let's see so this would be a
good time for me to learn this so I know
that normally when you have API keys
like this you want to put them in a
separate file that doesn't get synced to
your repo and then you just pull those
environment variables from there so
that's what I want to do but I actually
have never done that before because
normally it's like I'm not collaborating
with people on projects so I just have
private repos and it doesn't really
matter about the keys so let's do that
so there's normally it's like a dot n
file
I think that's let's um let's check this
all right so on my other screen just
proud of how to do this
okay so let's first make sure dot F is
in our yeah okay
so it's already in there good
although actually I wonder if these
files are already being used by create
react app
maybe
okay
so let me bring this over let everyone
see what I'm working on okay so as I
said all I'm trying to do is have a file
where I can put the API keys that I need
to use so that we can work on this and I
can put it on YouTube and not have to
worry about giving out any API keys so
this is saying I need to install dot
ends if I don't already have it which I
might I'm not sure
okay maybe not so I can do this and
store my sample increase store in a dot
M file
and just put the keys in there
all right does that seem like the way
it's supposed it's already set up okay
cool that's alright that's what I was
wondering
so Patrick says it's already set up I
yeah I was hoping you would say that and
I kind of thought that you might have
done that just put it on info I set that
up to work and server J ass awesome
okay cool Thank You Patrick
all right so I don't need this Tatsuki
already set it up so basically I just
need the dot and file and we're good
we're good to go
cool and actually now you say that did
you put something and github already
explaining that to me and I just forgot
it already even though I read it this
morning if if that's so sorry about that
all right well anyway my timer just
stopped so I did say I'd go back so I do
want to answer some of the questions
that were just in there so five minute
break I'm gonna answer some stuff in the
live chat we'll come back to it will set
up our API keys and test out nailing
widths in grid
okay so to go back to I want to go back
to this conversation we're having about
coding boot camps because I mean I
imagine this might be a useful thing to
talk about for people who watch this
so Tyler says I agree Jesse $10,000 is a
lot to me does a name recognition mean
anything
the umn is considered a top school some
you mm probably University of we have
what is what is um n we use just like
Minnesota or not
so buzzer is but well anyway it's
considered top school and it's highly
recognized by local employers so that's
another factor is considering okay yeah
well that's what yeah take that into
consideration so I think I'd mentioned
like our company's gonna respect this
you know boot camp certification or
whatever you're you know you're gonna
get when you do the boot camp and if the
answer is yes then that's awesome and
that's you know another reason maybe why
you should do it of course that depends
on like what company do you want to work
at and does that company recognize it or
not so that it that really depends on
what what you want to do
Oh jonbi said Internet Explorer 11
supports cons so wow I didn't even
realize it went that far back so that's
that's really cool
okay and Patrick brought up so the boot
camp will probably be partnering with
local businesses to help you find a job
so yeah that's that's actually a good
point you may be check-in to - what what
they have little kind of help they'll
actually give you to try to find a job
you know after you complete the boot
camp that might be really valuable maybe
if there's any numbers about like how
many people actually find jobs you know
within let's say like six months after
completing it if the percentage is
really high then it then it could be
worth it I mean then it could be a good
investment where you could say like okay
I'm gonna spend ten thousand now but
within a year I'm gonna have a job with
the salary that's probably going to be I
don't know way way more than that
so it could be worth it
okay kevin has any ideas on how to get
some title or experience in Columbia if
I just graduated in an unrelated
engineering degree I would say you could
do a few things so obviously like build
up you gotta build up your portfolio and
you probably build up like your
reputation in the industry possibly the
quickest way is if you could contribute
to some open source projects that are
popular then you might get more
attention from from companies who use
that product also like freelancing is a
good way to make money and build your
portfolio at the same time as long as
you can find projects that are good
sometimes there's a lot of freelancing
jobs out there that aren't really going
to challenge your skills would be bad
impressive in your portfolio so that's
good to pay the bills but you might not
even want to put it on your portfolio so
does that would be my what I would say I
mean it depends on what's going on where
you're at if there are different coding
meetups or conferences or things that
you could go to that's a good way to
network and just have people you know
get to know who you are and what you're
what you're into a project you're
working on and then that might be an end
so if you meet somebody from a company
and then you you find out there's a job
open then you could get in touch with
that person let them know you're gonna
apply they could put in a good word that
really goes a long way for getting hired
because it's a big decision to hire
somebody and if if somebody you know
inside your organization that you
already trust can vouch for them and say
yeah you know I know this guy
a good guy he knows what he's talking
about that could that could help so
anyway all those things will probably
help can't really say if any one of them
will be the thing that that really you
know gets you to where you want to be
but just working like a little bit at a
time you know as you can on on all of
them will be probably a pretty like a
pretty sure plan that at some point you
know you'll you'll build up your
reputation you know get a get a decent
job
okay so I'm gonna get back to this and I
just saw Patrick Road so dot and comes
with create react app and so Patrick
just required it in server DOJ's okay I
like I thought that I had seen it in in
the pull request so let's see is it
required
yeah there we go so it was in there the
whole time and I don't know I don't even
have to say it anymore like I I look
like an idiot so many times in this
stream like it's not it should not be
surprising to anyone anymore but that's
how it is sometimes
okay so Kevin said thanks to the advice
so he also said I'm awesome so I just I
just wanted to read that part out since
I just said that I look like an idiot so
anyway thanks for today bye Kevin yeah I
really hope that the you know some of
that advice will be helpful to you
it sorta I read something the other day
which it was really funny I don't
remember where it was that but it was
something like like listening to like
the successful like founder of a startup
company talk about how they did it is
basically like listening to a lottery
winner telling you what numbers they
used so kind it was kind of funny a
little bit extreme but it was funny
because you're basically saying like you
know there's so many things that go into
success you can't really just follow
exactly what someone else did so that's
why it's somewhat hard to give advice
because I could say like well here's
what worked for me that may or may not
work because my situation and all the
factors that went into you know what's
happened to me are probably not going to
be replicated so I I don't agree that
it's exactly like lottery I think you
can you can
you know good things you know away from
anybody story but it just it was funny
because it did kind of illustrate like
yeah I mean you it's really hard to say
like do this this and this and you can
replicate someone's success but anyway I
I think the advice that I gave is is
pretty general enough that it can apply
in a lot of different situations and
possibly be be helpful so anyway but
Kevin let me know how things are going
to if you ever have any like more like
specific questions or anything you know
feel free to get in touch with me like
on Twitter or wherever and I'd be happy
to help out like you've helped out me on
so many of my projects like I'd be super
happy to help you out with anything you
need jonbi said an awesome idiot that's
it yeah honestly legitimately like I
don't want to I get down on myself a lot
I don't want you all to think that I
really I don't really think I'm an idiot
I just think I make silly mistakes
sometimes on when I'm recording so I
actually have good self-esteem so so
don't worry about me that's all I can
say that and still smile and be happy
about it because I I really do have have
decent self-esteem so I'm not fazed at
all by messing up and calling myself an
idiot
okay so we already have thanks to
Patrick we have the dot M already
required so that's great so we need to
create the dot M file and then then I
can pull in my API key that I was
starting to set up on my other screen
from SendGrid
and that'll be cool cuz one needs to
make the eye keys for at least one other
thing we're gonna do maybe more
depending on
how much we want to set up let me check
the time as well okay let me I'm gonna
show you good as fast as I can to just
do a test and get this working and then
we'll do a question and answer in that
way
yeah because I need maybe about like a
half hour definitely when I try to wrap
things up in about a half an hour
okay
all right so when I set up where's my
cousin
so step one let's actually like create
the file here we go okay so here's our
file and I'll set up as much as I can
without revealing the API kids at some
point I will have to move this to my
other screen
[Music]
I'm should I name this that would be the
easiest gonna see what it's already
there we go so what are they calling
this SendGrid api key that's
straightforward enough
okay so
basically at this point I'm gonna move
this over I'm gonna put the API key in
but just for for demonstration so this
is what this is how you would set this
up correct
okay Patrick's just passed you're saying
do echo SendGrid API key equals your key
Val
okay so Patrick you're saying I could
just do that in the command line and it
would it would put it in there for me
but I'm like I could do it like this as
well correct
mokhtar says hey Jesse I'm watching from
Sierra Leone first time to catch it live
and I'm enjoying it
awesome I'm glad you could you can catch
this live that's that's really cool
thanks for watching
so all right cool so let's let me move
briefly I'm just gonna move this over
and then try to remember to never show
it again so I don't have to change all
my API keys and then now I'm gonna go to
SendGrid and set this up
oops gotta give it a name
okay
all right so we have our API key in a
dot and file so now this should give us
the correct API key and let's want to
double check to make sure I don't have
to do anything else to make this work
it looks like it's good yeah okay so
that should be in terms of ones on the
SendGrid admin panel that that should be
everything I need to do so now I think
we're I think we can do I think we can
try it
all right so save this what's good too
let's get rid of some of this stuff and
I don't really need actually I'm gonna
feel a little bit of sad just too
because I don't I don't think I
demonstrated my awesome console of that
I put in here also if you didn't see
yesterday and this if you didn't see
this in action will show that again so
I'm gonna submit and a lot of stuff
going on here
well more stuff than I thought I'd have
okay so anyway this is obviously like
these are all our keys and values for
our all our inputs right and then what
happened here
so I'm not sure what all that is oh man
now I know what it all is I did the call
so anyway it worked
I just got spammed with a ton of emails
though because I put the actual the part
of it that sends the email I put it in
here forgetting that this goes through
all the different fields so this ran for
every field so anyway it works it works
I got the emails I just need to not put
it in there so let's see where would be
a better place to put this
I guess I could just put it anywhere
within here will will run as soon as
this is as soon as a post request is
sent to upload anything in here should
one run right so if I put this in here
it should work I'll just test it I'm
gonna need to put anything in here
that's just submit it should submit yeah
okay cool so yeah so that worked once
awesome and I know I'm on my phone I I
saw I got a ton of messages to my gmail
account so hopefully hopefully I didn't
just like get my son Girt account marked
as spam by Gmail that would be bad
[Music]
sorry if there is just a bunch of static
I just had my phone right next to the
mic I didn't even realize it so sorry
about that
okay cool so we have
- anyway we've successfully sent an
email using SendGrid
from our server ejs file on form
submission
we've set up a dot M file so that we can
keep our API key secret we're not
committing that so we've added it to our
get ignore file so we are we are being
very sneaky and secret which is good for
this yeah so the next step would be
which I'm not going to do the next step
right now because I've gotta do a
shorter stream today but the next step
which may or may not be on Monday stream
depending on how much time I have to
work on it
is going to be not just sending this
where's that whatever we had whatever we
were sending this default text which
says Sanger it is fun sending a send
grid is fun and easy to do anywhere and
actually that was true this was pretty
easy and fun so we'll leave it in there
but what we're gonna do is replace the
subject and and the content with
probably the subject will say something
like submission received from and then
the person's email address our two email
is going to be we're actually going to
have two so it's going to be the email
of our project manager and the email of
the person who submitted it the from
email will be I don't know probably our
project managers email and then the
content will actually be all the values
that were submitted in the forum so
everything that was put in there so that
and that'll be it for the emails next
step will then be hooking this up to our
API and then after that potentially
setting up some sort of database
all right so I will take this I'll make
sure that I I push all this up to github
on the whatever blue branch are we on on
the custom server branch so push it all
up the custom server branch so you'll be
able obviously you can't test out the
email unless you want to put in make
your own SendGrid account and put in
your own API key which I'm just using
the free version right now which is
plenty for for this so if you want to
test it out there's a free version it's
really easy to use
okay now let's let's go to the live chat
actually Kevin said shouldn't it be form
dot on end let's see
yeah probably Kevin you're probably
right I'm just I'm not really familiar
with how things work with formidable so
I was reading their documentation but I
didn't get very far through it before
this video so that makes sense that
that's what it would be so probably
we'll move that
so let me
I'll work on that actually yet I want to
get you a question so I'll work on that
later on then because why if I get into
that now but I'm never gonna be able to
get through the other questions
okay so now if if you're just interested
in the code part that part is over I'm
going to do some questions and answers
now
so if you're gonna quit watching at this
point that's cool thanks for watching
I'll be back on Monday otherwise if you
have a question put it in the live chat
now I'll do my best to get to all the
questions if I happen to accidentally
skip over your question or if you can't
stick around to hear the answer please
put it in the comments or direct message
me on Twitter or some other social media
platform
okay so I've scrolled all the way up to
the top of the chat so I'm going to try
not to miss anything
okay so Tyler we were talking about code
boot camps and things and Tyler asks any
specific recommendations in the Midwest
particularly yeah I don't I don't know
of anything in particular in the Midwest
so sorry I can't give it give me any
advice in that area Patrick says there's
iron something in Colorado let's see
okay and it looks like if it was if it
was iron yard they shut down yes I
remember seeing that on Twitter
okay jonbi says general assembly seems
to be the highest-rated boot camp in
Denver okay I said never heard it I I'm
not really that knowledgeable about
which boot camps are good and which ones
aren't so good so I've never done a boot
camp myself so probably I'm not the best
person to give advice my advice in
regard to boot camps usually centers
around return on investment so I do have
a business degree and so my mind works a
little bit in that way and that I would
always be thinking what are the chances
of me getting a job how much would it
pay versus how much is this going to
cost
not only the upfront cost but then at
the time you know the opportunity cost
and how much time the boot camp is going
to be versus how much you could make if
you just been working so I would I would
put that all into consideration even
assuming that it actually was a good
boot camp
okay paddle says galvanized and touring
are also big in Denver but they're 20k
okay so let's say there's some
discussions about some really old
programming languages that I have at
least heard the names of these languages
I know nothing about them the naming
Lotus mosaic links
okay so Tyler did clarify what what I
thought it was University of Minnesota
so yeah I was wondering but then it hit
me that like I do like there are people
from all over the world so I'm assuming
it's Minnesota but maybe like it's some
university in another country and that I
I had just had never heard of so I just
wanted to clarify Sandeep says an accent
this was this was a little while ago so
hopefully you're still still watching
but Sandeep says this is my first
session do you think it'll be helpful
for me I'm okay to put extra effort to
understand old sessions and grim girls
so gr M&G URL says great question
Sandeep I'm in the same boat as you so
hopefully you all are still still
watching sorry I didn't see this earlier
but I yeah I think that I hope at least
that these can be helpful to people of
all skill levels sometimes I go over
topics that are a little bit more
advanced it just depends on what I need
to work on that day so on you know any
given day things might be a little bit
more advanced than then you might be
used to or they might be like ready at
your level or even below it so it just
depends on what I'm working on I do I
try to have a mix of things so I think
like maybe two days ago we were just
doing some basic CSS things and I was
the day we were doing the YouTube embed
so yeah it just depends and don't be
afraid to ask questions either you know
I'll I'll try to get to them when I can
but then also there's so many people in
the live chat that are really great at
helping out and answering questions as
well so yeah I mean I definitely
encourage you to don't just try it out
and see and if you find that the streams
aren't really that helpful at all to you
then that's cool too
and you know feel free to suggest maybe
some topics that would be more helpful
to you and I'll see if I could either
work them into my live streams with what
I'm doing or maybe make another video
like a pre-recorded video on them at
some point
Rohan said everything I do would be
one-third the time if I never made any
mistakes so this is right around the
time when I was calling myself an idiot
from faking silly mistakes so Patrick
had said we all make silly mistakes and
Patrick also said in in response to
Rohan that goes very well with how I
estimate I break things down into small
tasks estimate add them up together
multiplied by three that's really good
advice actually it seems like projects
always take way longer than you would
estimate because well for two reasons
one things not working right the first
time
you know silly mistakes and then also
scope creep which I don't know if I said
this yesterday but this project is
already gonna be bigger than I thought I
got some information from a co-worker
about some extra stuff that needs to be
in this project so I'm expecting I'm
expecting this to be more than what we
originally thought so I'm not exactly
sure how much more or what it's going to
be like but it's gonna be more hope like
it might just end up being that we have
a few extra views that we have to put in
and some text content and that's it
we'll see
yes sir says hey Jesse hey how's it
going thanks for watching
okay patch alright so I thought I didn't
see this earlier
I guess Patrick says you should be
hitting localhost 3000 now with the
changes to the start script okay so so
Patrick should I be able to do all the
form stuff on localhost 3000
I thought the forum stuff would only
work on the port 9000
okay let me try this then
so I do have 3000 open we do a refresh
so let me
let's make sure everything
oh okay alright so I'm getting I'm
getting this error this Coors error from
localhost
so at least like it did look like okay
so if I if I use 3000 then I still get
the hot reloading of everything in react
and then also the server so I just need
then to adjust the core stuff to for
this to work then
jonbi says in regard to having a
business degree says I started off doing
business it was too boring for me then
moved into IT Network administration and
then ported over to computer science
with concentration and networking and
data communications that's cool yeah I
was I I guess I liked business um in
when I was in school I focused a lot on
economics within you know within the
business department so I really I did
like economics I thought about going on
and getting like further degrees in
economics but then I just I did I got
married and I promised my wife that she
could get her master's degree while I
worked and so that was that I never went
back to try to get another degree after
that but I did I liked it but I'll tell
you what I didn't like so you know a lot
of people the business degrees go on to
be a manager of a business so I tried
being an assistant manager and I didn't
really like that I I don't know I just I
didn't like that part of it so I think
the the part of business that's more
like I don't know I guess it's it's not
dealing directly with managing people
but the part that's dealing more with
like numbers and trying to figure out
like trends and things I kind of like
that a little bit better
okay so let's so anyway Patrick's trying
to tell me how to get rid of this coarse
error if I understand correctly in here
I need to do this and then that will
allow everything right the problem was
it was only allowing things on port 9000
guess there's easy way to test it let's
see if it
hmm
I'm still getting that yeah try that now
I didn't I keep an eye on the time okay
maybe I could try I got to the end of
the chat in terms of the questions so
maybe I can take a couple more minutes
and just try to get this working before
we end the stream
would I have to change something in here
then
yeah I guess it's okay a Kevin says I
shouldn't he just it should be something
with this res header what was the
message
beside
it says no header is present on the
requested resource
okay Patrick saying you read that people
have trouble with cores on Chrome while
hitting localhost and nuclear nick says
there's a Chrome extension for this okay
cool I mean I guess I could try it on
another browser quickly bring in Firefox
okay I didn't get an error in Firefox oh
I mean this will at least this will let
us know if it's just a chrome thing that
we need to work on and let's see
which one screenshot yeah this is the
file that we just sent this screenshot
oh wait where did I go on did I get the
wrong thing
dang it I did sorry about that I went to
9,000 I was supposed to go to 3 so let's
try that again all right let's give it a
different file so what's this a
screenshot of once you cut it okay
okay so it looks like I didn't get an
error for that either let's see
okay cool that works alright so now I at
least we know it's something with chrome
so I just have to figure out what's
going on okay cool so nuclear Nick said
it's allow control allow origin is the
extensions name for chrome said it said
I literally had this issue a few days
ago and it was fine for dev environment
okay cool
all right Patrick I see now you're
telling me I typed the wrong thing in
okay I will check out the the extension
and see if we can get this working with
Chrome
okay cool
[Music]
all right yeah I gotta wrap things up
now so thanks thank you so much for
watching and for helping out not bad we
accomplished pretty much like what we
wanted to at least kind of like the
minimum that we wanted to today in
shorter than normal amount of time let's
see oh it's a nice Friday okay so I'll
be back Monday so have a great weekend
and I should be Monday might end up
being an earlier stream as well off to
see what what's going on with meetings
lately Monday's had been kind of busy
with meetings so we'll see so I'll let
you know on Twitter about when I'm gonna
stream sometime Monday morning so anyway
until then have a great weekend